he took away
a father he took away a brother he took
away a son he took away a grandfather
and he took away my husband
the family of a hotel security guard
pushed to his death have their say
before a judge issues the sentence eight
news now investigator David charns the
only reporter in court as the judge
ordered that man to serve at least two
and a half years behind bars
this is all the physical I have left of
my brother Randy 67 year old Randy Lyons
sister shows the court her necklace
containing her brother's ashes Pedro
Lozano had no regard for my brother's
life or safety in September 2021 35 year
old Pedro Lozano pushed Lions to his
death surveillance video the 8 news now
investigators obtained shows lizano
walking around the valet at the El
Cortez moments later Lions a security
officer for the hotel walks up to this
bench Lozano then rushes at him pushing
him to the ground Lions died months
later from a brain bleed even when he
could no longer open his eyes
he forced himself to lift his head off
the pillow
in a desperate attempt to say goodbye to
us lizano who took a plea deal last year
on a charge of involuntary manslaughter
didn't say much
as the news now investigators first
reported records show officers arrested
Lozano 49 times since 2008. he has eight
convictions for battery his attorney
David Westbrook noted lizano's past
attempts in mental health court the root
cause is that he has a mental illness
that he's been unable to treat and that
we as a society have been unable to give
him the resources to treat mental
illness cannot be used as an excuse
and as a
for very appropriately get out of jail
ticket Lyon's wife says she will never
forgive Lozano she told the court once
he's released she'll work to have him
committed I will be
The Thorn
in his side for the rest of his life
because I will not allow him
to go and taken away another son
another brother a sister
a mother of somebody
he will never do this again
Lozano's family wrote a letter to the
court saying he suffers from mental
illness ultimately Lozano could serve a
minimum of 28 months or up to eight
years in prison which is the maximum per
state law for this charge